[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis prof de philo c'est mon métier
c'est mon occupation du temps d'ailleurs
prof de philo c'est un des rares métiers
qui s'énonce en deux mots et dont les
deux mots sont des abréviations
professeur de philosophie prof de philo
les rares autres métiers qui s'énonce en
abréviation en général c'est plutôt les
métiers de la com pas la communication
laeken qu'est ce que tu fais dans la vie
je suis créé adam là comme je suis dire
comme je tape dans la com à l'accord
très bien et sinon toi tu fais quoi moi
je suis une chauffe route chaufferont
wesh au foot chauffeur routier
et sinon à toi tu fais quoi moi je suis
affirme wayne infirmiers arrêt d'accord
non c'est pas possible il ya des métiers
qui n'ont pas d'abréviations ou alors là
je suis sûr que vous vous dites tiens un
prof de philo il va remettre du sens
dans tout ça oui je sais pas si vous
avez remarqué mais c'est une sorte de
réflexe conditionné un philosophe un
prof de philo quelqu'un qui a un rapport
avec la philosophie
partout où il est invité partout où ils
passent sur les plateaux télé à la radio
il est là pour remettre du sens mais
quel sens et pourquoi vous avez quatre
heures
des formations profession quand je suis
arrivé en faculté de philosophie en fac
de philo pour étudier haydn chopin spino
ni mort ni tu ça marche pas c'est trop
con donc quand je suis arrivé en faculté
de philosophie mais objectif était clair
surtout ne jamais devenir prof de philo
tout sauf ça tous sauf être cette espèce
de flics sinistre qui débite du concept
au kilomètre le mec en noir sur son
estrade n'ont jamais de la vie
quel cauchemar bon en même temps j'avais
18 ans les choses ont bien changé depuis
mais alors qu'est ce que je foutais là
qu'est ce que je fiche est en fac de
philo
moi même j'en étais pas sûr est ce que
j'étais là pour trouver du sens est-ce
que j'étais là pour comprendre quelque
chose sur moi même sur le monde autour
de moi est ce que j'étais là pour
appréhender le sens de la vie le sens de
la mort du sens on fait de la philo
parce qu'on veut du sens mais non non
faire de la philosophie pour trouver du
sens c'est quand même un peu peine
perdue le philosophe n'est pas là pour
remettre du sens je vous rappelle quand
même que socrate celui qu'on considère
comme le père de la philosophie
occidentale
socrates legrand fondateur le big boss
socrates n'était pas là pour remettre du
sens au contraire l'objectif de socrate
et même de toute la philosophie antique
c'était plutôt de le bordel
d'ailleurs dans un dialogue de platon un
interlocuteur qui lui demande qui il est
et ce qu'il fait dans la vie
socrates répond je suis déroutant et je
ne crée que de la perplexité perplexité
quand vous êtes perplexe vous n'êtes pas
dans le sens n'êtes pas dans la réponse
vous êtes plutôt dans la perte des sens
la philosophie serait donc ce moment
d'étourdissements de vertiges profond
qu'on ouvre quand le sol se dérobe sous
nos pieds
c'est vertigineux et ça ne fait que
commencer
voyez finalement si on analyse les
choses
ce basculement total la perte des sens
qu'est ce qui nous reste
qu'est ce qui nous reste si on remet en
doute le savoir qu'est ce qu'il nous
reste si on considère que tout ce qu'on
sait c'est qu'on ne sait rien si noah
qui n'ont plus aucune valeur
il me reste moi-même moi être humain
dans sa nudité dans sa fragilité
il me reste le mois dépouillé de tout ce
que la société m'a appris dépouillé de
tout ce que la société m'a inculqué on
va reprendre l'exemple des présentations
avec les métiers
en général quand on vous demande qui
vous êtes vous répondez par votre statut
social toi tu es qui bat moi je suis
infirmière je suis chauffeur routier je
dirige une société spécialisée dans ceci
ou cela bah oui mais ça c'est pas vous
c'est votre statut social on a
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui ce que vous
faites vous définit plus que ce que vous
êtes
la philosophie vous répondra que ce que
vous faites n'a strictement aucune
importance
toi tu es qui socrates bah moi je suis
un type sans boulot ou qui va poser des
questions aux gens dans la rue toi tu es
qui diogène moi je suis une sorte de
clochards qui vit dans un tonneau et qui
se masturbe devant tout le monde
et oui le grand les grands penseurs que
l'histoire a retenu à la base c'est des
mecs qui vivent au jour le jour
ces mecs qui choque les gens autour
d'eux qu'ils font rien de bien utile
pour la société de leur époque
deux mille cinq cents ans plus tard ces
marginaux sont considérés comme les
hommes les plus sages et les plus
importants que l'histoire est retenu
voyez que trouver du sens suivre une
pensée c'est un tout petit peu plus
compliqué que prévu
blaise pascal blaise pascal disait que
le grand malheur de l'homme venait du
fait que nous étions incapables de
rester seul assis dans une pièce pendant
une heure sans rien faire et il avait
raison il faut toujours s'occuper
l'esprit branché notre conscience sur
quelque chose
tout ça pour oublier que faire face à
nous mêmes faire face à ce qu'il ya de
plus profond de plus véritable en nous
eh ben ça nous fait peur alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait bah on s'occupe dit pascal on
se divertit il faut avoir un métier
c'est important il faut avoir de
l'ambition
tiens je suis sûr que vous comme moi
dans cette salle vous avez des passe
temps c'est marrant à cette idée de
passe temps on dit toujours que la vie
est trop courte qu'il faut retenir
l'instant présent le faire durer d'un
autre côté il faut avoir des passe temps
pour faire passer les choses au plus
vite possible alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
avec le temps on le retient on le fait
passer imaginez vous êtes en train
d'attendre le bus ou le métro
qu'est ce que vous allez faire vous
allez faire comme 99% des gens autour de
vous vous allez checker vos réseaux
sociaux
moi aussi je fais ça moi aussi je sors
mon téléphone portable je tapote je fais
glisser je veux voir des photos je vais
faire un tour sur facebook et auto pitot
10 choses que vous ne saviez pas sur les
soeurs kardashian
je me fous totalement des cirques
kardashian mais je vais voir quand même
histoire de faire passer le temps avant
l'arrivée du métro tout pour ne pas
penser tout pour ne pas penser vraiment
tout pour éviter ce vertige existentiel
de faire face à nous-mêmes dans notre
dénuement dans notre fragilité et bien
justement c'est ça que nous propose la
philosophie l'inconfort je suis qui à
moi de répondre à moi de le dire et le
monde autour de moi qu'est ce que c'est
est ce que tout n'est pas faux est-ce
que tout n'est pas artificiel est-ce que
les vraies valeurs ne sont pas à
réinventer comme disait nietzsche
le problème c'est qu'avec notre manie de
vouloir à tout prix échappé à nous mêmes
nous finissons aussi par échapper au
monde autour de nous or le philosophe
pierre hadot avait une phrase qui était
très intéressant car ado disait la
philosophie est un effort pour
réapprendre à voir le monde
c'est intéressant parce que la pierre
hadot ne nous dit pas que la philosophie
est un effort pour apprendre à regarder
le monde mais un effort pour apprendre à
voir le monde ça veut dire quoi qu'est
ce qu'il veut nous dire pierre hadot
parce qu'il est bien gentilles avec sa
phrase ben il veut nous dire que notre
simple vision des choses
ce qu'il y a de plus pur de plus
immédiat en nous et déjà conditionnés et
que avant d'apprendre
il nous faut déjà désapprendre
désapprendre pour réapprendre
en bref plus j'avance dans les
connaissances plus je recule dans mes
certitudes
j'avance et je recule comment veux-tu
comment veux tu que tout cela aboutisse
à quelque chose
[Applaudissements]
et si tout ça n'aboutissait finalement à
rien je dirais si on considérait la
philosophie comme un voyage un long
voyage un voyage beaucoup plus important
que l'arrivée plus beau plus intéressant
un voyage fait pour renoncer à nos
certitudes bousculer nos habitudes
tiens une expérience philosophique qui a
tout changé au début du xxème siècle un
philosophe allemand du nom de in moun
une seule s'intéresse de près à la
conscience qu'est ce que c'est que la
conscience chez l'être humain
c'est bizarre ce concept de conscience
ça commence à exister en même temps que
nous ça s'arrête définitivement un autre
mort et encore on n'est pas sur la
conscience elle va s'arrêter de
fonctionner à deux occasions dans notre
vie quand on tombe dans les pommes
canton s'évanouit quand on est soudés
susan east voilà
[Applaudissements]
il y en a qui l'ont déjà vécu
vous savez ce que c'est quand on tombe
dans les pommes
quand on est sous anesthésie générale
qu'est ce qui se passe on n'a aucune
conscience du temps qui s'est écoulé il
peut s'être passé une heure il peut
s'être passé un an
on sait pas on peut avoir été déplacés
on peut avoir changé de pièces on peut
avoir changé de continent
aucune idée en fait notre cerveau a fait
une sorte de copier-coller entre le
moment on a perdu connaissance et le
moment on a retrouvé conscience etonnant
non
c'est pour vous dire l'importance de la
conscience c'est juste le truc nous
permet de percevoir l'espace et le temps
le truc sur lequel on ne peut pas vivre
et ça se fait dans notre tête
même pas besoin de réfléchir pour ça la
conscience c'est le truc le plus badass
de l'univers et quand il se lance dans
son analyse de fond de la conscience
humaine dans son étude phénoménologique
notre ami et demi-soeur renvoie à un
fait capital unique dans la nature
unique dans la création notre conscience
à ce pouvoir indépassable et
extraordinaire de pouvoir m l'univers
entre parenthèses au fond méditez
philosopher c'est ça prendre un tel
recul par rapport à nous mêmes par
rapport à notre existence notre corps
notre durée de vie limitée mais aussi le
monde dans son entier les mécanismes de
l'univers que nous approchons le vide
absolu le vide abyssal qui finalement
est tout ce qui est faire l'expérience
d'un univers où il n'y a plus d' espaces
il ya plus de temps et où je m'élève
jusqu'à la source de tous et cette
source
allez vous me demander c'est quoi ces
dieux c'est la vie ou alors y'a rien du
tout c'est l'absurde total l'absence de
sens mais vous pouvez peut-être que je
vais vous répondre
vous êtes sérieux là bas non à vous de
faire l'expérience
je vous invite à sortir des sentiers
battus de latence oublier les
obligations de résultat dans votre vie
dans votre travail dans vos désirs et ce
long voyage vers l'inconnu vers le
détachement ultime
vous pouvez tous le faire puisque vous
êtes tous en principe équipé d'une
conscience en principe si quand même
confiant
arrêtez-vous cinq minutes et fait face à
vous même mais sans vous poser de
questions ni sur vous ni sur votre
entourage
demandez-vous juste si ça vaut la peine
de s'agiter comme ça tout le temps de
vouloir remplir votre conscience votre
vie vos pensées et arrêtez de vous
sentir coupable
si ça se trouve vous n'allez rien sentir
ça va pas marcher
et alors les résultats on s'en tape
payez-vous un moment d'éternité et
arrêter de chercher du sens partout
parce que si ça se trouve et briand n'a
même pas merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]